hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter five
of the categories when Aristotle is
discussing substance or Lucia in Greek
which is one of the most important of
the categories there's a preliminary
discussion about substances and what we
call contraries a non TI this is a
important linguistic and metaphysical
term for Aristotle's understanding of
things and how they're related to each
other so Aristotle is trying to work
with with this notion of opposition or
contrariness to each other and you
notice some of the examples of things
that are counter at white black diseased
healthy warm cold bad good a also
included sweet and bitter which is
something that plays an important role
it has discussions of flavors and tastes
and things like that now this is an
issue that had puzzled
the Greek philosophers quite a bit how
could these these opposites or these
contraries be related to each other was
it in terms of substances or things
themselves was
in terms of something else so Aristotle
is working with this in providing us
with an explanation here so there's
three main things that he says in this
account that are particularly important
the third one is the most important but
let's go through all of them so the
first thing that he says is substances
themselves do not have contraries or
opposites now this is an interesting
thing to say because if we think about
you know how we represent things to
ourselves you know we say so-and-so is
the opposite of this person but what we
mean there is going to turn out that
they have some opposite qualities or
even that there's some other thing going
on there it's not as substances
themselves whether as primary that is
individual substances or a secondary
that is species or genus as these
classes of things are associated with
each other it's not as substances per se
that they are opposed to each other
it's rather substances understood as
being in a relation to each other
substances with a certain quality to
each other so substances as substances
do not have contraries Aristotle says
look it doesn't make any sense to talk
about something being the contrary of
human being how could first substances
have them this man for example that
animal nothing is contrary to them now
you know we do have interesting schemes
where we might say well you know dogs
are the opposite of cats right so we're
talking about two different species
there but they're not really the
opposites that's something that we're
adding to it there's nothing in the
scheme of things that makes dogs and
cats opposites to each other
in the way that say black and white or
cold and warm are opposed to each other
Aristotle also says that substances do
not admit of degrees or more literally a
a greater and a lesser so what does he
mean by that he means that insofar as
we're considering human being I am a
human being I am NOT
or human being then say you are or any
other human being we're all equally
human being we're at this is what it
means to be a human being now the
qualities of things do admit of a
greater and a lesser so we can say for
example one dog is a meaner than another
dog and one dog is sweeter than another
dog right or this person is smarter and
this person is Dumber or this person we
got to be a little bit careful relative
terms like greater and lesser like
taller and shorter but those work as
well so it's not just qualities or
quantities we can also talk in terms of
relation and the quality is the fact
that the qualities admit of a more and a
less might fool us into thinking
Aristotle thinks that substances
themselves have a more or less but they
they don't instead what happens is a
substance admits more or less of that
quality so if we talk about a person
being a better person than somebody else
that person has more goodness as the
quality and they could lose that
goodness and become worse right or they
could get more of it and become better
later on Aristotle will use an example
of Justice we can say that this person
is more just than that person just as
per se doesn't admit of a greater or
less or just as simply as what it is but
the person being just predicating just
of them because that's a quality that
they have that can be greater or lesser
what else substances he says remain a
unity and the same but they accept in
the Greek term for that is it's actually
Dec Taccone own that is they are
accepting they are you know taking in
they accept conscious
now what does that mean well if we use
this this you know sort of schema here
the substance itself has certain
qualities
it also has being a substance of that
sort so you know for example if we use
Aristotle's definition of human being or
account to human being rational animal
assuming that we're an adult right
rationality takes a while to develop
there's a whole story there that's part
of my substance those are those are you
know what it is to be a human being
animal rational there's a lot of things
that go along with that but then there's
also other qualities and so a substance
you know can have coloration white black
those are contrary to each other given
what we know about color these days we
can say that certain colors are also
falling into the scheme of contries so
you know we might be able to say blue
and orange or yellow and purple or red
and green are likewise opposed to each
other the way that white and black are
white and black is the example that
Aristotle uses himself and notice that
not every thing can admit these
qualities that are opposed to each other
a given whiteness or a of color cannot
become black and remain whiteness any
given color is what it is the the
existing coloration in something like
for example this book right this book is
green and you notice it's kind of a drab
--is-- green that has a bit of gray I
suppose in it or maybe some Brown Holly
I'm not an artist right or a person who
knows a lot about color unfortunately we
could change the coloration of this book
you know perhaps we put lemon juice on
it or something like that maybe that
changes it or we dip it in tannin and it
becomes browner we're changing the
coloration then it's not the original
coloration that is
you know receiving a new quality is
rather the substance of this this this
cloth that is receiving the quality and
is changing so the the qualities the
contrary qualities can come and go the
substance remains the same and admits of
one or the other this process of
accepting a contrary quality and thereby
losing the other quality is what we call
change Aristotle says so you know he
says we have you know changes within the
the quality of changes within the
substance itself substance admits of
contraries by having received or
accepted them into itself so if
something can go from being white to
being black can go from being healthy to
being diseased right go from being warm
to being cold happens to my coffee all
the time go from being good to being bad
or or vice versa go from being sweet to
being bitter the substance itself is the
thing that is changing the qualities
themselves are not changing there you
might say coming and going out of
existence in that thing in that
substance this is this is something that
Aristotle says is really unique about
substances he says what is most
characteristic or you know specific to
edie own of substances appears to be
this though it remains notwithstanding
numerically one and the same it is
capable of being the recipient of
contrary qualities of things that are
other than substance we could hardly
come up with an example that has this
characteristic and he uses some examples
you know a particular color numerically
one of the same can in no way be both
black and white an action if one in the
same can in no way be both good event
now of course this has to be qualified a
bit it can't be both good and bad in the
same way
the same time it could be good in one
respect and bad in another respect so we
could say well it admits these opposite
qualities but we're we're being you know
we're qualifying it in that case we're
saying in this way it admits this
quality in this way it admits this
quality but if we consider it as a whole
it's not admitting two different
qualities but we as substances and other
substances do in fact do that so this is
a very important feature of substances
it's like Aristotle says it's it's
really you know characteristic of
substances as opposed to other things
that they admit of opposite or contrary
qualities in ways that other things
don't